(slow mesmerizing music)
- [Narrator] This is a
Louisiana pine snake.
If we didn't show it to you,
you'd probably never see it,
or its distinct yellow and
brown splotched scales.
It's one of the rarest
snakes in North America.
The Louisiana Pine Snake can
grow up to six feet long.
It's not poisonous, it's a constrictor.
It wraps its prey and suffocates them.
Its known habitat is estimated
to be less than 200 square miles
in the Longleaf Pine forests
on the Louisiana-Texas border.
A habitat that is only 3%
of its once massive size.
It's almost impossible to spot in the wild
because the snake spends
its time below ground
moving through the tunnels
of its rodent prey.
But when it pokes its head above ground,
its habitat is in steady decline.
Fewer trees mean fewer
rodents burrowing beneath,
and that means fewer pine snakes.
And with encroaching human development,
the ever present threat of being crushed
under road traffic looms.
This is Louisiana pine snake.
(slow mesmerizing music)